[Musik]
bild grips
es bereits an diesem freitag einen ganz
schönen guten tag ihnen und heute morgen
kam diese nachricht rheingas gerd ist
auf die barrikaden gegangen ja gerhard
schröder verklagt im bundestag ja denn
der altkanzler und putin freund will
jetzt seine sonderrechte zurück die
wurden im jahr im mai entzogen und jetzt
verlangt schröder eben dass ihm wieder
ein altkanzler büro mit mitarbeitern und
und und zur verfügung gestellt wird
schröder steht ja wegen seines
engagements für russische energiefirmen
und seine nähe zu putin massiv in der
kritik erst vor rund zwei wochen
besuchte er ja putin und jetzt will er
also sein büro und seine mitarbeiter
zurück käme ein paar interessante zahlen
dazu für personalausgaben schritt das
büro hat bei einem vergangenen jahr mehr
als 400.000 euro aus der staatskasse
geflossen oder müssen darüber reden
würde ich auch sagen bei uns ist unser
bild parlament chef ralf schuler guten
morgen herr
einiges bekannt jetzt in den letzten
wochen vor allem noch mal besonders die
aufmerksamkeit gerückt gerd schröder gas
gerd war ein bisschen nervös
hättest du das jetzt erwartet und vor
allem was bedeutet das jetzt wer
schröder kennt kann da nicht ganz
überrascht sein mein parlamentsbüro hat
übrigens kein budget von 400.000 euro
recht und anstand sind zwei ganz
unterschiedliche sachen
schröder hat in der zwischenzeit
endlicher mandate niedergelegt das heißt
die büros die ihm aus diesen tätigkeiten
ohnehin zustanden wo er seine
wirtschaftlichen tätigkeiten abwickeln
konnten die sind weg das könnte der
rationale grund hinter dieser klage sein
das andere ist diese streichung der
stellen im in seinem büro das war
rechtlich eine sehr heikle geschichte
man muss sich einfach klarmachen dass
diese
büros die fahrer der personenschutz ist
eine extra geschichte gehören zur ruhe
geldausstattung das ist wie bei uns die
rente und man kann auch niemanden einem
normalen bürger der jetzt permanent zu
schnell auf der autobahn fährt sagt du
bist ein raser hat kriegt nur die halbe
rente das geht nicht man darf mit der
rente nicht bestrafen und da kann er
sich auf diesen standpunkt stellen und
kann sagen ich habe mir das
zusammengestrichen zumal um eben nicht
rückwirkend in bestehendes recht
einzugreifen der bundestag zu einem
kniff gegriffen hat und hat gesagt du
brauchst das ja gar nicht die deine
mitarbeiter haben gekündigt die büros
stehen leer dann können was auch
streichen muss ja nicht darum stehen
jetzt sagt er gut ich brauche das ich
will es wieder haben das wird ein sehr
spannender prozess auch wenn das ganze
natürlich vor dem hintergrund von
schröders aktivitäten ein sehr
schlechtes geschmäckle hat da kann man
gar nicht großartig drum herum reden die
frage ist was er mit diesem büro
eigentlich noch machen will aber es
steht ihm zu und es ist erst nach seinem
bezug geändert worden selbst
bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel bundeskanzlerin hd wie sie
korrekt heißt hat ein büro etwa von der
größe gerhard schröders und hat sich
intern sogar auf ihn berufen sie will
das gleiche haben wie er hat also das
heißt er hätte jetzt durchaus chancen
dass alles wieder zurück zu bekommen das
ist gut möglich wenn er geltend macht
dass er es braucht diese büros sind
gedacht für amds nachwirkende
tätigkeiten das heißt alles was mit dem
amt zu tun hat fanpost das organisieren
von reisen wenn er reden hält als ex
bundeskanzler all das kann man dort
machen was man nicht machen kann sind
wirtschaftliche tätigkeiten er darf dort
nicht seinen geschäften nachgehen und
darf auch nicht
irgendwelche dinge dort veranstalten die
privater natur sind also das ist genau
geregelt und ich bin gespannt wie das
ausgeht also ihre geschichte ein ex
kanzler den bundestag verklagt das
meinst du wie geht's jetzt weiter mit
schröder gestern war ja auch kurz thema
beim kanzler beim jetzigen kanzler bei
olaf scholz der da so sagte der
pressekonferenz neuer kann sich nützlich
machen hier steht eine turbine rum nun
immer noch steht die herum wir warten
darauf dass putin die abholt in der
sache ein bisschen na ja da kann er
sicher einsetzen also auf schritte
angesprochen würde wie bewertest du
jetzt seine rolle jetzt in den kommenden
wochen auch innerhalb dieses konfliktes
wie er sich darstellt und die jetzt
darin gipfelt dass er den bundestag
vertrag das ist eher eine ungute rolle
er macht ja immer geld das er den
gesprächsfaden nicht abreißen lässt und
dass seine kontakte hilfreich sind um
den ukraine konflikt zu entschärfen
faktisch gesehen hat er nichts erreicht
das muss man ganz klar sagen und putin
hört auch nicht auf seinen alten freund
gerd sondern macht das was er was er
will aber die turbine dahin bringen kann
da habe ich auch so meine zweifel
das brisante an der ganzen geschichte
ist man muss wissen dass das
bundestagsbüro die büros und
liegenschaften des kopierpapier und das
alles das wird vom bundestag und von der
spd fraktion bezahlt und unterhalten die
stellen die in diesem büro freigehalten
werden die also dort auch ich glaube
personalkosten bis zu 400.000 euro
verursachen die sind im kanzleramt
angesiedelt das kanzleramt
gestalt sozusagen das altkanzler büro
ist etwas verwirrend auch für haushalt
nicht leicht zu durchschauen insofern
hat scholz da schon ein gewisses
interesse daran dass das nicht allzu
peinlich für die spd und ihn eben dann
in der folge wird also spannende
entwicklung vor allem das alphorn also
dann auch mitarbeiter findet selbst
sollte er sollte er damit durchkommen
wir hatten ja zuvor auch gekündigt haben
gekündigt sicherlich schwierig werden
weil ein damm danke für deine
einschätzung
[Musik]